Russia in the way in Ukraine one week
ago I think the warm
changed so much about me
yeah I'm miserable all the time I'm
terrifying from my friends and family in
Ukraine
people already dying kids are dying
you're watching the lines to the Border
or what people standing to the line to
supermarket Jovi jugan took line Lake
looks like miles of flying to get food
yes
Yara has been having a really hard time
hasn't really been sleeping a whole lot
she hasn't been eating a whole lot do
you want to maybe try to put my last toy
together get your mind off of things a
little bit or what you're good yeah I
get it
I know she's been really nervous she's
been crying a whole lot she's just been
staying on the phone like all day with
friends and her family which even though
I don't like it I want to spend time
with her I understand what she's doing
I've just been trying to support her in
whatever way I can you know I support
um I supporter country too
all right miles we're gonna put your new
toy together your new kitchen okay
oh my God
will that make you happy
what
did you show in high cave they all build
and explode
she just makes me want to throw up I
swear what's the latest have you talked
to anyone about what's going on in our
life they're sleeping right now they say
that they were getting a little bit of
sleep did you show where they sleep did
I saw your picture where they sleep look
at this level sent to me look
my mom was in Czech Republic so she's
just perfectly safe but my family is
located in Western in Western Ukraine
right now and my friends are located in
Kiev
so July for my uh French right now it's
uh in the day in the bathtub
and at night they are under the ground
foreign